foreign
[Music]
we've talked about a lot the last few
times that we've spoken but I'd love to
chat maybe about
the heart surgery and your recovery from
the heart surgery which I think
might be
perhaps a inspiring place to start for a
lot of people would you mind just
describing the heart surgery and what
the recovery has looked like
for yourself
you're referring to the most recent one
which was 2018 or 19 it was 18.
and
that was when I just went into a
routine
a non-invasive
aortic valve replacement
but it goes through your arteries
on your arm neck and then your growings
into your heart
and then they replace your valve
it's a standard procedure that they have
now in the last 10 years
and you don't have to perform open heart
surgeries anymore because of it
it just happens to be that in my case
they had a difficult time somehow
and they poked through the hard wall
with the cable
and so I got internal bleeding
and they now had to perform
an emergency open heart surgery
and of course was not aware of any of
that because I was out
the next thing I know is I wake up
in a really happy
and this is over
only to find out that I was having a
breathing tube on my throat and I
couldn't talk
and I saw three doctors in front of me
not smiling but kind of having a
concerned look on their face
and
one said don't try to talk because you
can't
you still have a breathing tube in your
mouth
and we're gonna pull that out right away
now so just stay with us okay one two
oh
so I was breathing heavy and someone
ripped the breathing tube out of my
mouth
and then
the second doctor said oh we are so
sorry Arnold but
something went wrong with the valve
replacement
and we had to perform open heart surgery
so it digested all that and also the
breeding the bushes ripped out of my
kind of throat
and lungs
and
so I'm still kind of not saying anything
it's just look staring at them and the
next thing the next doctor says yeah
it's like 16 hours later now
since you were first put down so now we
are keeping you awake and everything
hopefully will be fine the most
important thing is now for you to make
it through the first night because
that's usually when you can have
pneumonia
and where things go south
and so I was like saying there was a
I'm just gotten out of open heart
surgery
where it could have cost my life
and now they're telling me this is next
night or two is very crucial so I don't
lose my life
so I said what the hell is that
what kind of a deal did I go and get
into here so anyway the bottom line is
is that it was I had to kind of connect
quickly shift gears and realize what has
happened which takes you a while because
you're on drugs and your medication if
you're still on the anesthesia somewhat
and do not be the program so also slowly
started getting with the program I had
to kind of shift gears and I realized
that the simplest things were impossible
to do couldn't go to the bathroom I
couldn't get up I couldn't do this
because that and then slowly I started
getting with the program instead of
pulling out the tubes during the night
and decided adjusting this and adjusting
that and then eventually
I was able to go and get up a little bit
and so now the doctor said this is the
key thing is to walk
because if you walk
then you exercise your lungs and when
you exercise your lungs the danger of
having pneumonia starts really slipping
away and you don't have to worry about
that but the key thing that kills you
always is the least amount of lung
activities that you have can create you
know
this problem and you die with pneumonia
and so I was either by setting goals for
myself okay I'm gonna go and walk around
the bed right away I'm gonna get up have
someone put along the machines then
after I walked around the bed they sit
down again and relax a little bit then I
went outside to do this and so I got to
make it outside the room and instead of
going outside the room back in again and
outside the room again in celt like
doing exercises like that eventually I
was walking around the nurses station
and then eventually
two days later I was walking down the
long hallways over to another building
and back which was like hundreds of
yards
so I could really build up strength and
you know get out of that hospital as
quickly as possible and so after six
days rather than what they thought seven
days after six days I got out of the
hospital and I was exercising and I was
walking and I
ask friends of mine
that were working out with me to put the
pressure on me and my family my kids and
everyone put the pressure on me to make
me walk and do not let me get away with
not walking and so that's exactly what
we did
see you've always seemingly been very
good at setting goals having a vision
and then setting these intermediate
goals I'd like to rewind the clock
because I was trying to find some
some aspects of your life that we
haven't explored already is and this is
going to go back to age 10 so h10
roughly is it true that you were selling
ice cream at the time I think there are
ice cream pops or some type of ice cream
you can't believe everything you read on
the internet but I did find that and I'm
wondering if that was one of your first
experiences with entrepreneurship or at
least trying to make money by selling
something you absolutely correct and it
was not
that I wanted to become an entrepreneur
or anything like this at that point what
it was was just really a necessity
you know I felt like
I needed a training suit
friends of mine had training suits in
the winter
and you know tennis shoes and I didn't
and my parents refused to buy it you
know they just would give me my leather
housing you know the pants that they
were day and night and and in the winter
in the summer and then some high shoes
boots and
just closed it with work all the time
and but nothing fancy so and I wanted to
have and I go to the soccer field than
whatever training suit so they said well
you go out and make your own money
that's fine you can buy your own stuff
but you definitely you're not gonna get
it for us because that's not the kind of
money that we have and that's exactly
what I did so I went downstairs to the
lake
where I grew up
and where I learned how to swim
and they asked there was a ice cream and
dessert kiosk in front of the big rest
around right near the lake
and as I asked him I said do you have
anything
that where I can go and put ice in it
and then carry it back there where the
people are lying around in the middle of
the grass in the bushes
and all around the lake that are too
lazy maybe to come to the front here and
buy the ice cream here and you know have
it melt on the way back there and it's
gone already it says that there's some
people I think this was maybe the
entrepreneurial kind of mentality
because I felt kind of there is maybe a
need for someone like to deliver the ice
cream to those bushes into those
different locations around the lake
rather than have them to go have those
people go all the way to the front to
get the ice cream
and so I did not know but I thought that
maybe it would be interesting idea let's
try it so I would just take a little box
that the guy gave me was like some kind
of a container you normally put water in
it and some of the rounds kind of
contained through the handle on it and
he put in ice
from the winter that they when they've
cut the ice in the winter under the lake
they used it in the restaurant below for
keeping because there was no
Refrigeration yet keeping the drinks the
beer and the vegetables and everything
cold so they had broken ice huge amounts
of broken ice in the bottom of the dress
around and so the guy had in his trunk
there where the ice cream was this ice
in it so it gave me a little bit for my
container and then he put in 20 ice
creams they were like you know just
icicles so that the spas and he put
those in there's a little bit of
cellophane a little kind of paper over
it and so I ran with those around the
lake
and I said in ice cream ice cream fresh
ice cream ice cream the name is often
something with pop-up is yeah I want
some ice cream and then I would go with
the little Bush and they'll be sweet
guys like there with a girl and so this
is give me four ice cream okay four so
the next two or four so by the time I
was like a hundred yards gone I already
was out of ice cream from my pocket so
to run back to the front again get more
ice cream and go back out again and
that's what and then eventually I just
took 100 with me you know and there was
enough ice underneath to keep it cold in
that hot day
I was around 30 35 degrees and so I sold
this ice cream and then the end of the
day
I ended up what this guy gave me one
shilling for each ice cream so I sold
like 145 150 180 ice creams and
somewhere 180 Shilling so that got me
enough money to buy myself a training
suit
then the next weekend they will go back
and I will buy myself with the money and
some tennis shoes and stuff like that
and so this is kind of how I started to
realize that if you work your ass off
you can really accomplish a lot of
things that's why my book you know be
useful I put in there this is a main job
there's just work your ass off work your
ass off and we're definitely directly
gonna segue to be useful so seven tools
for life
this title be useful
could you explain
and that's probably ties into similar
chapters around the story around earning
money and working your ass off in your
younger years
where did this title come from be useful
it comes from a father
even though he would always say that
and
his whole attitude always was
whatever you do
try to serve the people try to do
something good for your community or for
your family don't just think about
yourself that's why my father was so
heavily kind of against bodybuilding
because you felt like that there was he
was called This is Subs Throne
themselves Throne which means you're
conflict glorifying and you're treating
yourself
rather than worrying about others and so
he just felt like he says instead of
lifting for yourself why don't you go
out and chop some wood
why don't you go and suffer some coal
and this way you help some older person
that has cold delivered shove a call
into their basement so they've called in
the window and they have wood in the
winter and you help an older person that
doesn't that is not able to do those
things anymore that's what you should do
then you get all the muscles and you
also get strong then you also can can
kind of look good look at this guys like
Laszlo pop
is a boxer from Hungary he was the
European champion in boxing the how does
he train he does pictures all over the
place where he's chopping wood in the
forest I said that's how he trained
that's how it becomes a boxing champion
he doesn't just think about his boxing
things about other people too so there
was this wrap and so he says you're
going to be useful you know you got to
go and use your talent to help people
and so that's where it kind of came from
and it's something
that was really interesting because
I think you and Abby talked about that
in the past that sometimes things come
to you as a kid
but then later on in life it kind of
comes back it's like kind of united six
o'clock in the morning and you want to
stay in bed and you say you said wait a
minute I heard his voice from my father
screaming be used for
you know people have never accomplished
anything no country ever was built by
people sleeping in you know Austria was
the built that people sleeping in
America was not built by people sleeping
in people struggled people suffered
people broke their asses off to build
this country so do you want to go now
and sleep in you know so then you start
feeling guilty and you'd just jump out
of bed right away because those sounds
you hear those sounds they come back and
it's kind of motivational because it
really has driven me my whole life and
has pushed me but that's why I called
the book be used for because it's kind
of a no more title and then within that
book I put all the chapters in there you
know if it is you know I have a Clear
Vision or you know never think small or
work yourself or sell sell sell and all
of those kind of things shift gear so
whatever it is you know I've put this
kind of lessons together which were very
crucial lessons that I've learned
throughout my life and throughout the
various different careers especially in
the gym most of my lessons I learned in
the gym because there's no better place
than to learn in the gym because this is
where you know the
the rubber hits the road right I mean
this is where you if you don't do the
four strips
and if you don't work until it burns and
until it hurts and then you go beyond
that and do the four straps you're not
gonna grow
so now you get this message that only is
through pain you can actually grow only
through pain you can go and discomfort
and misery you can kind of grow as also
as a person not just physically not just
muscle wise but as a person through
Comfort no one ever grows you know the
only girl can grow some confidence going
through you know things where you have
to have discipline and where you have to
where you struggle if it's in the
military if it isn't a real good job or
if he's studying in the university the
mother's kids struggling and study all
night and and go through hardship the
further they're going to go look at the
students that goes through medieval
college and all this stuff how much how
many nights and sleepless nights they
have and all this so This Is What It
Takes how did your father say be useful
in German what is the way to say that
properly or how would he say to you well
he would have different versions of it
he would just say
right you know work hard work hard
interested in yourself so it was kind of
like a combination of all of those
things that he was through together and
he was just obviously you know kind of
like be very critical of people that
didn't do that
remember that my father's job was a
police officer
he was with the shender Marie which was
the country police
it was all about protecting people
and keeping Law and Order
so that's serving the people
and the same is when when you talk about
music
music is to entertain people
so this whole thing about learning to
play to play music and to play six
instruments the trumpet the flicking one
the saxophone the clarinet of this
different you know in instruments it
made him a great performer he wrote
music he conducted music so it was all
about what can you do for other people
so he would go to the state to the city
park out there and he would have
concerts he would play concerts he would
play in funerals and everyone a police
officer died he always played the
funerals and direct the music and
conduct the music and all of that stuff
so he was always interested in serving
the people and so he was really into
that
Arnold what I think about you the
adjective that comes to mind I was I was
asking myself this question earlier
today that the adjective that comes to
mind for me is resilient and uh many
people have seen the Netflix miniseries
Arnold and one of the lines that I'm not
going to get this perfectly right that
stuck out to me was that your upbringing
made you but broke your brother and I'm
probably getting the phrasing off a
little bit but I'm wondering if you
could just elaborate on that a little
bit and speak to what the upbringing was
like and then also what made you
different from your brother
in that respect
I think that my brother was
the nature more fragile
and
I never really
realized that when I kind of grew up but
just the very fact
certain things that kind of unfolded
made me didn't realize that
and there was
two things one of them was that he was
more fragile
and the other one was that he appeared
to be more fragile
and that I appear to be stronger and the
reason I'm saying that is because like
for instance when he was like 11 years
old and he was going to school in
droughts
outside the village and he had to go
with the bus there then they had to be
picked up at the bus station a half an
hour away from our house and there was
night in the window in the fall and then
he was afraid to go home
he would say I'm afraid to go home by
myself
and so my father would tell him he says
well Arnold can you pick him up
like if you're Shilling every night till
you pick him up so we're going to end of
the week five Shilling her is it because
since Saturday it was only half day
school so he would go home at the time
and it was still alive
so I said them oh yeah yeah I picked him
up no problem he says you're not afraid
I said you're kidding me now but in the
meantime I was also scared shitless
so I appeared tougher
than my brother but I was also afraid
but I was not afraid enough
not to go
so I did go even though I was afraid my
brother refused to go because he was
afraid so there was both that was a
little tougher than him but that I also
pretended to be tougher than him so
there's a kind of unfolded as time went
on so as we were punished and beaten and
all of this kind of things that was
going on it was clear that my brother
couldn't quite handle the thing because
he ran away
more often from home we're not only
Boston ran away because I never ran away
so he ran away
and he would not appear something for a
week my father would have to look for
him all over the place and he was scared
did he get lost he was gone or what is
going on so he freaked him out
and
he treated him for a while when he came
back home he treated him from for a
while nicer and then you know he started
getting to be again too much for him so
what happened was really when I looked
back was that each time her father
punished us
it made my brother more and more
vulnerable
and weaker
and it made me stronger
so I thrived on that kind of like my
mind started gearing up to
I'm gonna get back at him
I'm gonna leave this house as soon as I
can I'm gonna be out of here with the
age of 18. I'm gonna go to the military
and then I'm gonna go and get my
passport and then I'm gonna go to
Germany and then I'm gonna go to America
and I'm gonna be out of here this is it
I'm not going to take this any longer
and it would make me stronger and really
set a program and set a goal in the
vision of what I'm gonna do in life
whereas my brother crumbled he got
weaker
he started drinking
he started getting involved in alcohol
and I could see in his behavior
that they didn't behave well
he was abusive
and
and eventually he died
because of a car accident drunk driving
with the age of he was I think 24 and I
was 23 when that happened I was already
in America at that time but it was like
it was really sad because I could see
that he just could not handle anyone
with the punishment and I could I was
thriving on it and I used to do my big
plus and as a support system and it was
like all about kind of like gave me the
motivation he created the fire and the
belly it made me a Creative Vision about
a necessary Vision this is what I want
to do I want to get to America I have to
become a bodybuilding Champion I have to
get away from home I had to find my a
new father figure my father was great to
be the father the official father but
there were others the trainer and the
weightlifting Club could manual and mui
there was a guy that could now that we
also know there was in his 40s and 50s
that became a father figure very smart
guy that spoke English and was very
worldly and then there was a Jewish
fellow there that became our kind of
mentor and helped us with the
weightlifting Club so this wall became
kind of my new father figures in the way
and then eventually Joe weirdo when I
came to America and all of these people
I looked up right over as an idol
because they would kind of like treat me
in a better way and they will educate me
and they were really you know kind of I
should be along and nurture me along and
uh so but I never really rescinded my
father because of it I always kind of
felt
that he served a really extraordinary
purpose for me
not for my brother but for me which
means to get me to America to become a
great Champion to have that will to be
able to work
no matter how many hours it takes
to do no matter what it takes
and do not shy away from misery or from
pain or from obstacles or from falling
down and having to get up again and
crawl and all for for nothing and there
was the power and the strength my father
gave me and so I've always kind of like
appreciated that
and nothing comes in the perfect package
because I know that if he would have
given me all the love
and if he would have not done none of
that and if I would have had all the
money in the world I would have not
grown up as tough and I would not have
been able to accomplish what I did
Coming to America and becoming this
world bodybuilding champion and do all
the things that I was that I was doing
it was all because of that upbringing
and so when I look at for instance my
in-laws
you know when I see those kids they're
very smart kids in the Kennedy family
but I always felt kind of like they
couldn't have grown up
like Maria or Maria's brothers or you
know anyone around them they couldn't
have grown up or my children couldn't
grow up with the same desire and the
same hunger yeah but they can get other
qualities and so that's the key thing to
focus then on that but I mean they could
never have that quality of hunger and
desire and deep inside kind of like
reach being able to reach inside no
matter what it takes
so let's talk about one of the rules
never think small you seem like the
walking archetype of not thinking small
you've lived multiple lifetimes compared
to most people
how would you suggest people think of
never think small or what stories come
to mind that from your life exemplify
that
was just the very beginning I mean for
me to go and say the junior Mr Europe
competition rather than just in the Mr
Austria competition it would I trained
just as hard as everyone else in the gym
the goal was just smaller they said I
want to be Mr Austria and I said I want
to be Mr Europe so I'm going to start
with Mr junior junior Mr Europe the best
build man of Europe I'm gonna go to this
competition and I was thinking bigger
and that was training as hard as they
were everything was the same but then
when I won that competition because I
had a very clear Vision that's what I
want to win that immediately launched me
into getting a
job to become a trainer in Munich in a
bodybuilding gymnasium
now imagine
how in heaven is that your young
bodybuilder you're 18 years old you just
want your first International
competition you win some local
competitions in Austria you win some
power lifting competitions some
weightlifting competitions but now
you're a junior Mr Europe
and you have this Trophy and now you're
getting a job to train in the second
biggest gym in Munich so that was like
absolute heaven so with 19 I started
training become the trainer in the gym
so now I had the opportunity
to train day and night when they wake up
because I was sleeping in the gym
I was waking up and I was training I was
taking a nap in the afternoon I was
training I was going to sleep before
going to sleep at night after dinner I
was training I was training day and
night so this is a dream but it was all
because I thought big they were still
stuck working for some bath house in
Austria or for the government or being a
trash collector or being a teacher or
something like that they were still
stuck in the same job I was already
moving on to Munich and I was already a
trainer in a bodybuilding gymnasium
making this the launch pad to America
which was my Ultimate Dream so this is
what I'm saying so it didn't take more
work
to think big it's just thinking big just
thinking big makes you bigger and what
my point is it takes just as much effort
so I my whole and I learned again from
bodybuilding from that kind of thing I
learned that don't hold back so when I
went within age of 19 I was the youngest
Mr Universe competitor I competed in a
Miss Universe contest and I want I
placed second I placed runner up
so that a year later I went back with
the age of 20 and one Mr Universe the
youngest Miss Universe ever but this is
all because I was thinking big I was not
saying oh maybe in a few years from now
I go there or I shouldn't go there right
now or something oh it's too early
orders and then there's just another
thing right away I'm gonna go for the
second Miss Universe next year I'm gonna
go to America I'm gonna go and make Joe
Wida aware of me and you know make sure
that they win another competition
indoors so I was driven bigger and
bigger and bigger and even when I got
into acting I didn't look at it as kind
of like I'm gonna get some character
roles I wasn't interested in character
roles I wanted to be another Steve
Reeves or rage Park they were the stars
of the Hercules movies Clint Eastwood
was just a star we always Clint Eastwood
you know in the fist full of dollars
Clint Eastwood in a dollar a few dollars
more clean this to it and then you know
in this movie whatever it was it was
like I that's what I wanted Charles
Bronson I want to be like Charles
Bronson I want to be like one baby I
want to be like this guys they were the
top stars and that's what I saw myself
and they said well this ladder is very
hard to climb up
I said well then I built my own ladder
I built my own ladder and then I know
exactly how to get up there that's
exactly what I did I created my own way
of getting up there I took five hours
that I learned in bodybuilding and it
took five hours every day of working my
ass off to train and to train and to
train and do pose and to post and to do
all the stuff that they needed to do I
said I'm gonna do the same five hours
but I'm gonna go and learn English
I'm Gonna Learn acting speech lessons
voice lessons accent remove lessons well
I should get my money back for those
but in any case I took all of those
lessons one hour every day and I was
grinding it out and then I remember
eventually it happened people started
hiring me and the great thing was
that I felt
that there should not be financially
vulnerable so I'd first got into real
estate and I worked my ass off in real
estate my first million actually made in
real estate before I really got into
acting
and that helped me because now when they
came to me with stupid parts and says do
you want to play a bouncer I said
no but when I play a bouncer
I don't want to be a Nazi officer I say
I want to be a star I want to be a
leading man I want to get rich and
famous just looking at these with
Charles Bronson and they said you're
crazy it would never happen well I
applied the other room which is don't
listen to the naysayers so I work my ass
off I did exactly what I did in the
bodybuilding I did in the movies
eventually it happened I started doing
the chain Mansfield story I started
doing it with Kirk Douglas with and and
Margaret the villain I was doing Streets
of San Francisco I was doing stay hungry
and pumping iron all in the 70s and even
with Lucille Ball doing happy
anniversary and goodbye so I did all of
those kind of things and then that led
the big role and now I've arrived
starring Roar in Conan the Barbarian you
know when John Miller saw me he says if
we wouldn't have Schwarzenegger we would
have had to build one so all of a sudden
the body that everyone said would never
ever become famous in the movies because
the movies
no one is seeing Muslim movies anymore
of the opposite came true my accent
became very welcome when the
determinated they loved the German
accent which Tim Cameron called
Schwarzenegger's talking like a machine
that's why it worked in the Terminator
you know so things like that so all of a
sudden the things that they said would
never make it in Hollywood you know the
accent the name the body all of the
things became big pluses and it made it
so that's the my own ladder that I built
that's why it's important you know don't
just worry about climbing a ladder that
someone else has built no build your own
ladder you know just don't wait for
anyone else so that's what I did three I
wanted to underscore a few things for
folks number one the building of the
ladder was not many ladders was not
haphazard it was systematics he had the
real estate as a financial buffer which
gave you then the ability to pick your
shots and you've been very good at
doubling down on betting on yourself in
many different areas could you speak to
Twins and
what that looked like with that
particular film to bet on yourself
well twins was a little bit out of
nowhere because I had certain goals
but comedy was not one of my goals when
I got into movies
and I felt like that I can be funny in
the movies in the encounter and there
were funny moments and all that stuff
but only when I started doing one action
movie after the next
you know my Hunger
you know the whole philosophy of staying
hungry kind of came out
a little bit and somebody said well I
wonder if if you ever could sell the
idea of me doing a comedy
and then all of a sudden I started
getting obsessed with the idea
and instead of talking to everyone I
said have you ever thought about me
doing a comedy and of course every
Studio executive said are you crazy I
don't I mean what do you think I'm
making my millions of dollars if you're
being an action hero you finally built
the after the bit it is in the National
Action here alone in America but all
over the world why would I go instead
spending money on something else that is
not sure
I love the action movies we're gonna
give you all the scripts for action
movies
and so I said yeah but I understand but
what about me doing an action movie for
you and then the next one we do is a
comedy no why would I do that you tell
me I mean would you do it I said yeah I
say but here's the thing what we need to
do
so then when we finally formed the
partnership Danny DeVito Ivan Reitman
and myself
we got together and he said you know
I can sympathize with the studio why
would they take the risk
for what
why don't we all take a risk
why don't we go to them and say instead
of us getting the big salaries
why don't we just saying we did the
movie for nothing
just give us a back end you don't have
to pay us any salary whatsoever
if the production costs 16 and a half
million dollars
that's all you use that one penny more
for us us
don't worry about us at all we have
plenty of money and if the movie goes in
the toilet we all go in the toilet
everyone takes the risks not just you
the studio wouldn't be fair would it
they said hey this is my thinking guys
you guys will be really good so what do
you want in return we said all we want
is just you give us three
37 and a half percent of ownership of
the movie and then we all go to the bank
together if the movie goes through the
roof we all make money the movie goes in
the toilet none of us make money
they said we are in that's exactly what
we did and it happened to be
with Ivan reitman's genius directing
and we tended to be the kind of great
great acting and everyone else around us
a Kelly Preston and everyone else
and me being involved we made the movie
a huge hit as a matter of fact
that movie made more money than any
action movie made up until that point
for me so my action movies went over to
like 70 80 million dollars
and that movie made 128 million dollars
domestically and worldwide
250 million dollars so now
imagine the budget being 16 and a half
million dollars and you box office is
250 million so now we own 37 and a half
almost 40 percent of that chunk
so we all cleaned house
it was so funny to go around as
a matter of fact
Tom Pollock
who was a fantastic studio leader and
great producer and lawyer
he after the deal he's just basically
said
he went around the desk in his office
and depend over and pulled out his
pockets and says you guys me and
robbed me blind and so it was like we
were all we're laughing because we all
were very good friends I mean he was
right I mean like it really because they
were so worried about the risk-taking
that we said we take the risk and true
enough we did and the the risk paid off
and so we just really cleaned the house
so I made like I think 70 million
dollars in Twins or something like that
then and then he made a forge that he
bought two houses built two houses so we
all got kind of a lot of money and Ivan
Reitman and so and so they said that's
what deals that we did then in the
future with Kindergarten Cop we did it
with Junior we did it so it became a
model that no one is going to do in the
day anymore the students got smarter
than that so no wonderful steals anymore
but anyways it was like historic kind of
a deals but it was I had the confidence
that I could pull it off and and Ivan
had the confidence in Dania the
confidence and so together we all did
and Universal Studio then at the
confidence and they promoted it really
well we hired any liberowitz to do the
photo shoot and she took us on top of a
bus against the blue sky and just
photograph Dane and me leaning against
each other and that became the poster
and it was like really genius so
everyone kind of worked together to make
this a brilliant move in the successful
movie
so this ties into cell cell
why have an entire
chapter slash rule dedicated to sell
sell because for a lot of people they
think of selling as a dirty thing I
don't happen to think of it that way but
why is this so critical that sell sell
would be one of the primary sections in
the book
you can imagine
the reason why I called it sell sell is
because it does raise eyebrows right it
does make people say wait a minute
selling normally is a No-No I mean if
you think about it that every most of
the actors in the 70s
and it is refused to sell the movements
they said this is not my job I'm an
artist I don't sell I'm not a Salesman
out there and all this stuff and I this
was my strength because I started
selling when I was in Career Education I
started to be a Salesman and so I
realized then
the importance of selling that no matter
what you have
if you have a podcast
if you have a movie
if you have a painting if you have a car
a technology a medicine whatever it is
if people don't know about it you have
nothing
the more people that know about your
product or about your talent the more
you can go and be successful so
therefore this idea of selling
publicizing marketing communicating
convincing all of those kind of things
is an art
and those odd agencies that make
millions and millions of dollars to
stick out what the language should be in
order to really sell to the right people
and if the right customers and sell a
product the right way so it's an art to
do that
and I've learned it way back when I was
15 years old and I learned how to sell I
remember when my boss said to me says
now look at watch me carefully
when I sell there's this couple coming
in this couple comes in and they want to
do I worked in a in a store that had you
know wood products and it was like a
lumber yard it was kind of like a
hardware store type of a thing so this
couple comes in they want to have tiles
and so immediately the guy started
talking and then my boss started talking
to the guy and said what kind of tiles
do you want do you want the black towels
or pink tiles or white house and then
guys said this is well I don't know so
the woman said I really want white tiles
and for the bathroom we want to have
pink tiles
and so the guy looked at her and says
okay fine let me take you over there he
said how much space how much tile do you
need again demand didn't answer and the
woman answered and just say so I need to
send it to me I was written down the
measurements here and it's two meters by
a meter 80 tall and blah blah blah and
so the guy then all of a sudden realized
that she's the customer
so he started really paying attention to
her and asking all the questions and
thinking around but included him also
and then on the end when they were
satisfied and we wrote up the order and
we then told him that they would be they
will be all delivered on Thursday
he came to me after they left they said
so what did you learn I said well I said
did you really sold the the tiles well
and the colors and the difference
between real tiles and fake tiles and
all this he says no no but it was one
other thing
I switched
who I thought was the customer
he says she was the customer not him he
paid for it
but she was the customer so I had to
talk and address her because that was
the important thing she needed to be
convinced so I had to sell to her and so
I realized then
selling is an art
that you have to improvise and adjust
all the time that you could go in front
of a children audience for instance you
have to speak a totally different
language when they talk in a class in
the school in after school programs then
I talk in Washington when I talk to
legislators I have to talk to
differently when I talk to a crowd of
fans at the movie theater then I talked
to a bunch of lobbyists so it's always
different so you have to learn the art
of selling and this is why selling is so
important and I remember that when Andy
wow when I was being painted in his
Warehouse
down in SoHo
and Jamie wise was there and Andy war
was there and he always talked about
that the most important thing is that
they don't just sell the art but you
sell yourself
you have to sell yourself you have to
become a kind of a interesting person
we've got parties you go to who you hang
out with you know the photos that you
take the recordings that you make the
magazine that you publish and all of
this together it says makes me a
character
and makes people fascinated to write
about me and therefore they write about
my art
and true enough it worked because in no
time and it was Art became worth
millions and millions of dollars I used
to I used to buy it for
fifty thousand dollars thirty thousand
dollars I have the big Indian that is
hanging in my office that is now you
know 10 15 million dollars about for
thirty thousand dollars
so imagine the value that Andy Warhol
gained
by being just a character a different
character and being just strange to
people with a wig on it and it glasses
and all these different things he ran
around with a little tape recorder and
he by the way was a great promoter of
mine
what is the significance of Shifting
Gears I mean people can think of it of
course in an automotive capacity but
shift gears what does that mean to you
and are there any particular stories
that stand out
related to that well I mean shifting
like to give you an exam I talked about
it earlier you wake up from a surgery
that you think is two hours they replace
your heart valve and then someone tells
you they poke through your hard wall and
you now have been out for 16 hours and
now you have to stay here six days of
seven days and you know we're you're not
out of the woods yet you know we have to
do everything we can to keep you alive
and you know you almost died on the
operating table and it could still
happen next night you know if you don't
really get going with the walking and if
you get pneumonia so that you have to
shift gears very quickly I usually call
it the art of improvisation you know
that you have to be very good in
improvising because there's a lot of
things that come up to you in life but
you have to be really good in
improvising and this happened to me all
the time when I was governor at the
quickest shift gears and it happened
also in show business where you have to
shift gears but it's the unexpected is
happening and you have to be kind of
like ready for that and confront that I
mean that's the most important thing so
it's just it's just so many people get
stuck on certain things and the track
and they then cannot get off that track
I just always felt like I was very good
in shifting gears like going from
bodybuilding to show business I mean you
really had to shift gears because
obviously and certain other things
became important I mean think about it
you go and you do bodybuilding every
athlete always tells you that you got to
go and keep the Motions out of the way
because it's the emotions that gonna
kill you you cannot go and train and
compete and train for a competition for
a world championship or the Olympic
Games or whatever it is and be
emotionally involved in whatever it is
you know because you can derail you it's
okay so you do that that become a master
in that I became like Cornerstone
but then all of a sudden
you go and you start taking acting
classes
and you start
hearing from the acting teacher
Arnold
you talk like a cold
fish
there's no emotions there I got to go
and find your emotions
so think about that for a second all
your life longer here now that this is
like
bad and now all of a sudden you hear you
have to be more emotional
you have to be in touch with your
emotions
have you thought about lately
the smell of a rose
as it's the self what a rose
says
a rose smells a certain way it's a
beautiful smell
she said what does this have to do with
acting this is ah
he says if you sit there on the scene
and you start thinking about that smell
of a rose
you have a totally different facial
expression
you close the eyes
you know let's assume that you want to
compliment the woman the perfunctorious
you can go as this I like your perfume
stupid
but if you go and say
what are you wearing
ah
it smells wonderful
I mean you have good taste you know this
is that's a totally different town it
says it would change your voice if you
smell the rose it would change your
voice
but you only can do that if you really
smell it
and be in touch with it so that's what
I'm talking about shifting gears very
quickly so from one year to the next I
had to kind of all of a sudden have all
the emotions kick in yeah and make
everything work that didn't really work
in the past so I'm curious to ask you
about
how that
re-accessing of emotion maybe has
informed how you experience
grief
yourself since we last spoke you lost
Franco Franco Colombo and I'm just
wondering what that grief was like for
you to experience
I have to say I react a little bit
differently to those kind of things with
everyone else
because
to me it's not so much the shock
as it is
the ongoing
missing a person
because
there's certain friends
that have become part of you
and so if they pass away
and they die
something dies in you
and so when I imagine every day when I
walk into my living room
and I see this chessboard
where Frank and I played chess in the
last
10 years
two three times a week
you drink wine
smoke this doggy and just talked in the
talk like
65 and 70 year olds talk rather than
the way 20 years or stock you know like
in the old days
and because Frank I've known since I was
18 years old so then our conversations
were differently than than there was
they were as of the last 10 years when
we talk about kids where we talk about
family when we talk about that we grew
up in the but the past and it was kind
of like deeper conversations and more
emotional
conversations and now all of a suddenly
every day when you walk into your living
room you see this chess table down the
corner uh Franco is not sitting there
anymore
that to me
you know it's heartbreaking
and when I go to the gym and they drive
down with the
bicycle
and Franco came on the bicycle right he
was not good in bicycle riding he was
all over the place that was funny and I
had people sometimes videotaping you
know just to show how goofy he looks in
a bicycle I think the bike seat was
maybe too high up
whatever the problem was it was just
hilarious because he was in a 5-3
according to him I think he was five one
of five two the most but anyway he
always said five three
and then working out with him the fun of
working out with him
then I had him in so many movies
I remember when I directed the movie
the switch
the tales of the crypt I had him in the
encountered the Barbarian item in
Terminator I mean the Adam in all those
movies in there so he was just he became
you know kind of part of me so to me
it's not just the initial shock
When someone tells you oh Frank it's
just passed away on the beach in
Sardinia
it is also then a daily thing a weekly
thing a month is every day every time I
go to the Arnold Classic
and we hand out the I have a trophy
that is the Franko Colombo posing trophy
or most muscular man Trophy and we hand
those out and we Frank his body on it
that I got made by a really great
Italian sculptor the double bicep pose
and
and the double bass are both
intentionally
because Franco was really not never
known for his biceps
because he was known here so his head
such overpowering back
his lats his chest his deltoids it was
so overpowering that people who
sometimes didn't even see the arms so I
on purpose wanted to do a double bicycle
so in the future people also remember
him for his biceps but it's just a great
great sculpture so Demi Franca will live
on forever so he's showed her
you know on Ben weeder and Dave Draper
and Sergio liver and Bill Pearl and reg
park to me I see them all sitting in
front of me when there's the Arnold
Classic
and I see them all sitting there
laughing and having a great time and
watching gown with classic and watching
how bodybuilding is progressing other
cash prizes are going up are we have
bigger and bigger sponsors and we have a
bigger and bigger convention an expo and
all of this how they enjoy all that so
that's what I see out there now and but
it's it's kind of like you know it's in
between kind of like should have tears
in my eyes when I'm out there and
looking at all those faces of this
bodybuilding Champions and promoters of
bodybuilding
or should I smile you know it's this
combination of things
I would love to get your thoughts on
aging and relating to aging because a
lot of people struggle with relating or
thinking about aging I for the first
time in the last nine months have had
chronic pain for the first time due to a
spinal issue which is the first time in
my life I've ever experienced that and
I'm wondering if you could share
anything about what you've learned or
decided with respect to
aging just getting older as we all do
you know the first time at all I
experienced something similar to that is
when I had my open heart surgery
I was not even 50 years old
it was in April
and in July I'm 50. so it was
it was just a few months before I was
50.
and it was the first time where
I woke up after two heart surgeries the
first one didn't work so they did a
second one within 48 hours
and
after that I felt like
I was damaged goods
I didn't feel any more like
invincible
and I didn't feel like I can handle
anything
all of a sudden
there were limits
put on me
where the doctor said don't train as
heavy
every time you force your reps
you put pressure on your valve
unnecessarily
we have to replace those valves again
in maybe 10 15 years from now
so the more you put pressure on it the
faster we will have to it's like a tire
30 000 miles per tire you can use it up
in one year you can use it up in 20
years so it's up to you
you know it's that kind of a thing so
it was the first time where I started
thinking about when I did stunts
I remembered it right after that
was a stunt
in End of Days
where the woman that was possessed by
the devil
takes the piano and runs it against my
chest
wanted to kill me
so
and normally you can run the chest
there's a piano into my chest it doesn't
make any difference I don't care
right so but because of the heart
surgery
and having been now cut open on the
chest I did not know how vulnerable that
rib cage is
so I told them to measure out
the distance with the Rope
and then the Rope comes to an end and it
stops
an eighth
or a quarter of an inch before my chest
so it looks still like it's smashing
foot in and I still sell it but it was
it's like you start planning
on your vulnerability
and this then continues on
because all of a sudden
you know you used to kind of hop
upstairs and hop downstairs in a
squatting position to just get out of
breath so that when you start a scene
you exhausted you know like you're
cutting in in the middle of a fight
scene so that yeah
and you have the big breath
so all of a sudden you start jumping up
and down
and your knee start hurting
so now you realize you get between 1560
it's the knee punishment
so I have to watch my knees
then
after your 70 you said for the first
time saying you know I noticed myself
walking less
why am I walking this I used to love
hiking for five hours up the Steep
mountain and all of this in love where
am I walking less
then I realized that I got back pain
when I walk
a long time I started getting cramps in
my back so I started walking less so I
started doing stretching exercises for
the back
and so that things like that start
creeping up then you have to start kind
of really be disciplined and say okay I
still have to walk soon so many miles a
day too many steps a day and blah blah
blah but now you have to make yourself
what came normally natural so you get
kind of like one thing after the next
then you have shorter surgeries on both
shoulders and like yesterday
I had elbow surgery because my nerve had
to be kind of
relocated because where the Nerf was
it created pressure many of and
therefore my little fingers started
getting numb
so now that comes in that's in the late
70s
this always said distribute the nerves
and someone talks to you about the
neuropathy
about your legs and feet and this is how
it just you know creeps up on you all
this stuff and the interesting thing is
it's like
weight lifting
it doesn't matter
how old you are or how young you are it
doesn't matter how rich you are it
doesn't matter what color you are it
doesn't matter from where you're from
200 pounds
is 200 pounds
it's the same thing for
everybody and the same is also when you
get older it makes no difference
who you are who can be the biggest
celebrity in the world
but you still get your back pain you
still get your hip pain you still get
your shoulder pain you still get your
elbow pain you still get numb fingers
you still have to watch your heart you
still have to watch the diet you still
get fat if you don't watch the diet you
eat three times a day or four meal you
get fat you have to cut one meal out all
of this kind of stuff you have to start
doing so it's just that simple and this
is all kind of so that we stay alive
longer and that we kind of like because
we all are the time you've won
your time cut is set
it's set
the only thing that changes it is
you
right so let's assume I'm set for 85.
so I can decide
do I want to go to 90
yeah I can do that but then you have to
live really healthy
someone else has said for 90 you can
lift 100. but so but you can stretch it
a little bit
and
you can also it up big time it can
be said for 85 and you wipe up with 70.
you know my dad wiped out with 66. yeah
it was in pension for one year and then
he wiped out he died because of too much
smoking and alcohol and all of those
things so he cut himself short he maybe
was meant to be 80 but he definitely
wiped up with 266. so my mother
you know she died with 76.
well she did it herself because I mean
she had a congenital heart disease which
is what I have which is the valve
but she's the choice to get surgery or
not she says no if God wants me he
should have me
and so she resisted any surgery
but that's how we basically kind of
there are some people when you watch
those shows in Sardinia they live to
100. because they have no
problems
you know the what they sleep in the
afternoon to take the Naps they eat well
they walk around for miles and miles
every day they still walk and work I
mean the women are still in the kitchen
with the age of 90 making food for the
whole family and all this stuff so they
push it they push the envelope Beyond of
what they were meant for so this is the
way we can do it but I mean
I think there's a reason when you get to
a certain age to be concerned about it I
don't know if it's the age that you're
in now until you're still a young punk
I can hope they're here for your whole
life wherever you could be my grandson
so you've been an athlete right as it
was laid out in the three chapters in
the miniseries athlete actor American
right you've had this this Arc
how do you think of your self now like
what is your identity now and how do you
hope to use the time that you have left
because of course you have this book be
useful seven tools for life you have the
newsletter which is done very well you
have more than half a million people for
pump Club you have the pump app
but how do you think of yourself now and
and what do you want to focus on
in the next 10 years if you have let's
say 10 years left something like that
well I don't really think of myself
now any different than I thought of
myself and it was governor when I
thought of myself as an actor as a
bodybuilder you know I'm very rarely in
the moment of where I just appreciate
what I'm doing right now because I
always think about the future
you know I don't like the past I
appreciate the presence but they really
live for the future I always just live
about where I want to go there's a lot
of things I want to accomplish
environmentally there's a lot of things
that I want to accomplish when it comes
to public policy there's a lot of things
I want to accomplish in Show Business
there's a lot of things that I want to
accomplish in the promotion of health
and fitness and bodybuilding so all of
these different worlds I hopefully can
manage to combine them and create a
certain Synergy and was it that one can
help from the other so the bodybuilding
can help from their Show Business my
success in Show Business the show
business can help get help with the
success of the fitness movement then my
newsletter that I have which is going
through the roof right now the pump cup
all that is kind of like playing into
this whole thing I'm very happy that all
of a sudden now it's it's kind of like
an unexpected new the error for me which
is the era of motivational speeches the
era of motivational books the era of
motivational newsletters I mean not in
my wildest dreams they ever think about
that I want to create a positive Corner
in a an internet
and there was only because there was
just so much negativity out there
instead of thinking about well maybe I
should say some nice things and some
positive things and it became a huge hit
beyond my expectation and so I now I do
speeches every often if it's the
Ukrainian War
the Russia when Ukraine or if he's you
know the Insurrection of it is prejudice
or whatever the issues are I I tackle
those so as I said to you earlier I'm
the guy that climbs up on diverse and
sees another bunch of pigs and therefore
I say oh my God they didn't even know
they were there and they climbed them
and so that's what I do this I just a
continuous climb nothing changes I
climbed with 20 I'm climbing now
what do you hope the impact of of be
useful will be
what would you hope people to
gain from it or use it for
I think that the whole thing is about
helping people
live a better life and kind of be able
to fulfill their dreams whatever those
dreams are you know it's just simple
things like that don't listen to the
naysayers or create a vision and I know
that because I ask my kids when they
were like 18 19 years old what do you
want to do why I want to go to college
they couldn't answer me
well I could answer the question but it
was 18 19. you know so I'm concerned
about that because the cinema they're
looking too much in the computer too
much on the iPhone than on the iPad and
they get ideas from someone else but
this is their ideas but not their ideas
that my kids Society is they need to be
by themselves and sit in the Jacuzzi or
sit since I'm in a mountain or out there
by themselves who said thinking
let the dreams come into your mind let
you to deep inside come out and give
yourself time don't always look at the
machine and so I'm trying to tell people
this is simple rules that I talk about
in the book
where you kind of learn you know that
here is how I create a goal because
without a goal without a vision you have
nothing where are you going to go you
know it's like he's having an airplane
pilot
eventually crash that's what happens to
you in your life you crash you're not
gonna go anywhere so you need to have a
direction you need to have a goal why
you get up in the morning what are you
struggling towards what it is why are
you happy to go to bed at night and you
need some rest to get up in the next
morning and after the energy again all
of this has to have purpose
there has to be purpose so this is what
I try to do is keep a little bit of this
light in my book and say the people in a
casual way when you have a goal here's
how you can do it this is how I did it
you know and then in a big big course
don't be afraid of because in a big
chorus they're just as easy as do as
little courses you know and by the way I
know that every human being is afraid of
failure
but you can overcome that you know by
accepting failure in a win body building
we go and do a failure with our reps
so every single day when we train we
experience failure if you're not afraid
of it because Muhammad Ali said hey I
used to me to send them I said when are
you how many reps do you do in sit-ups
he says I don't start counting until
it's such hurting us they're failing
that's when it's not counting so that
shows your I mean in lifting you can
only know how much you lift if you're
willing to fail so you know every if
Michael Jordan when he talked about his
5 000 chance to be missed in basketball
and how many 280 some games he missed in
in basketball and all this stuff that's
what made me great
well wow that's a that's an eye-opener
you know when you hear that that's
really that's really powerful the
greatest basketball player talks about
failure that made him great so people
should look at that they should start
thinking about that don't start
approaching everything with oh I'm
afraid what is if I fail what is if he
doesn't like it what if I make a fool of
myself well you know it's people afraid
of speaking public speaking that's the
biggest fear that people have because
they are worried that they may fail or
sound stupid and stuff like that you
can't know that you gotta get rid of all
of this in a worry about failure and he
will be then free
another thing you will be able to get
rid of it completely we can never change
100 but you can change someone so that
you're not as Afraid Anymore failure and
that you're actually looking forward to
that and that you're saying okay I'm
gonna go all out and do a fail
you know that you approach it
differently that the way you look at
failure and look I've always pushed
myself what do you think when you run
for governor
I mean it would be the highest
embarrassment if he would have lost
right but that took the chat I was not
afraid of failure I could see my vision
very clearly this is how I'm gonna sell
to the California people
what I'm going to do for Californians
and that's how I'm going to approach the
governorship of blah blah blah and you
know if they buy in great
if they don't
then they're lost then they move on with
something else but I'm not going to
freeze now and say oh my God but if I
lose but then I would have never run in
the first place if I would be afraid to
run right so you never know how far it's
going to take yourself I think Simple
Rules like that I wanted to have those
people take away those rules and or for
instance giving back
as soon as you realize that you're not a
self-made man
and you realize that we all were created
by your parents
and did you were created by mentors
teachers coaches and many other people
that none of us know but you yourself
know
I mean those are the people that have
created me I mean it's just alone if I
wouldn't have had Joe Wheeler to bring
me over to America
how could I have come to America
so how can I say I was self-made
how could I have become governor if not
5.8 million people voted for me I mean
I'm not a dictator I was voted in to the
Democratic process so did I make myself
governor no so I'm not a self-made man
so I have to recognize that by training
my money everything comes from a lot of
different people
and therefore
that means when you recognize that that
you now have the responsibility of going
out and help others
there are so many people out there that
need help it's like my father-in-law
said
Sergeant Shriver who was who created the
Peace Corps Head Start Job Corps and
office great programs in the 60s
he said to a bunch of Yale students at
the at the graduation class
he said tear down this mural did you
always look at yourself
tear down this mirror and you will be
able to look beyond that mirror and you
will see the millions of people that
need your help that's exactly right as
soon as we start
per minute looking at ourselves
then you will be able to look Beyond
yourself when you see that there are
people out there that need help that
there are poor people out there that
need help that fire victims right now
out that they need your help the
earthquake victims out there there are
homeless people out there the War
veterans out there there are kids that
come from poor backgrounds that out
there that need to learn how to English
how to speak English rather write
English how to do math and all of the
stuff that's immigrants they don't even
speak English so there's so many areas
where you can be helpful that takes
money or takes no money just effort so
never ever think it's all just about you
someone helped you where you are today
so now you go out and help someone else
so this is another one of my lessons
it's just you know
break that mirror in front of you so
these are the different lessons that I
teach people that really had a profound
impact than me and made me successful
and the no rules and anyone can
follow it that's what it is so people
can find the new book be useful seven
tools for Life anywhere find books are
sold they can go to
beautifulbook.com the newsletter can be
found at Arnold's pumpclub.com and we'll
link to all this in the show notes at
tim.blog podcast Arnold is there
anything else that you would like to say
any closing comments or other requests
of the audience suggestions anything at
all that you'd like to add before we
come to a close
no no I just want to say to the people I
want to thank them
for having been such great supporters of
mine
and
you know without them as I said earlier
I will be nothing
I mean if it wouldn't have been for the
bodybuilding fans as I grew up they
would cheering down screaming Arnold
Arnold motivated me I will be nothing
if it wouldn't have been for the movie
fans that went to run to see counter the
Barbarian made it the number one box
office that then gave me all the
headlines I would have been nothing all
the gym cameras and the island ripements
and all of these people and the people
that are now following my newsletter the
pump cup and all this people that are
even interested in a book like you know
they'd be used for and to go to my
seminars
and listen to my speeches my
motivational speeches I've just really
loved that I have had such an
extraordinary following and that some of
my speeches have reached like 35 and a
half six billion people that's really
extraordinary so I want to say thank you
without them I will be nothing and thank
you to America for giving me everything
thank you Arnold for the time yet again
absolutely thank you Tim